california considers universal health
care and doubling its taxes and l.a
times columnist makes the case for
mocking unvaxed americans who die of
covet and democrats insist on running
against january 6 2021 in 2022. i'm
bench bureau this is the ben shapiro
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with vpn so should you
visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here's a reminder
inflation is currently at 40 year highs
this might be a great time to think
about diversifying see here's the thing
historically like throughout history
people have valued gold gold has never
been worth zero there's a reason that
leprechauns hide it at the end of the
rainbow they're not hiding government
bonds at the end of the rainbow because
you might get to the end of the rainbow
and inflation has eaten away the value
of the pot at the end of the rainbow so
if you are interested in the
leprechaun's gold or any other type of
precious metals as a hedge against
inflation and uncertainty you should be
checking out birch gold today right now
inflation rates are higher than the
interest on treasury bonds so that every
day that passes the government owes less
on its mountain of debt imagine if your
mortgage had a negative interest rate
would you start paying it off no you
absolutely would not your pain is their
gain so protect your savings right now
hedge against inflation with gold from
birch gold because the government is
sabotaging the value of the united
states dollar and it's only going to get
worse over time spend to 98 98 98 get a
free information kit on gold and when
you buy before the end of the month
birch gold will send you a copy of my
newest book the authoritarian moment
text ben 298 98 98 to get your free
information kit right now today text ben
298 98 98 to get started alrighty so i
have to say that each and every day that
i look at the news from california i i
am just delighted by both the news and
the fact that i i no longer live there
because they've just decided in
california to go pedal to the metal we
are going to destroy the state as fast
as humanly possible according to
ktla.com california lawmakers on tuesday
will start debating whether to create
the nation's first universal health care
system
a key measure of whether the proposal
has the support to pass this year
progressives have tried for years to
create a government-funded universal
health care system to replace the one
that relies on private insurance voters
overwhelmingly rejected a 1994 ballot
initiative that would have created a
universal health care system another
attempt passed the state senate in 2017
but it died in the state assembly
because there was no funding plan
attached to it this year democrats in
the state assembly in california where
democrats have a super majority have
filed two bills one that would create
the universal health care system and set
its rules the other would lay out how to
pay for everything by raising taxes
unquote some wealthier individuals and
larger businesses as we will see they
mean we are going to raise taxes
massively on pretty much everyone and
destroy all business in the states we
can pay for the health care for illegal
immigrants which is really what they are
talking about in the state of california
because the reality is that
poverty-stricken californians who are
american citizens are still eligible for
things like medicaid illegal immigrants
are not eligible for things like
medicaid however california now wishes
to extend quote-unquote universal
healthcare to everyone now there are
other states that have experimented with
this sort of stuff in the past so for
example vermont tried universal
healthcare years ago right the bernie
sanders attempt vermont tried healthcare
reform
they created a state-level single-payer
healthcare system in 2011. by 2014 they
said we can't do this anymore within
three years they were like yeah this
doesn't work we can't pay for any of
this that was in vermont which has seven
people and an elk
so think about california which has a
population of 40 million people and
they're not talking about providing
universal healthcare what that means is
that they're either going to have to
pursue rationing or they're going to
have to pursue massively higher taxes or
both that is what universal healthcare
means in the state of california because
right now there is an under supply of
medical care in the state of california
if there's an under supply and over
demand this means you either have to jog
the supply by paying doctors a lot of
money or you have to artificially lower
the demand by rationing care right those
are the only two things that you can do
in order to make supply meet demand at
the governmental level
the bill is getting a hearing on tuesday
before the assembly health committee
where chair jim wood a democrat from
santa rosa has already said he'll vote
for it because the proposal was
introduced last year it has to pass the
state assembly by the end of january to
have a chance of becoming law this year
universal healthcare has been debated
for decades in the united states state
lawmakers in vermont of course as i say
tried and failed to implement their own
universal health care system new york
considered it and then they're like nah
but california peddled to the metal
stupid supporters in california are
adopting a divide and conquer strategy
this year
they are trying to separate the idea of
a universal healthcare system from how
to pay for it because the minute the
californians realize what exactly they
would have to pay in order to ensure any
legal immigrants don't just go to the
emergency room and clog up the emergency
room
once they realize what the cost is on
that they're like yeah i'm not so sure
we're into this universal health care
thing
assemblyman ash kalra democrat from san
jose and the author of both proposals
says we can debate the policy if someone
says how are you going to pay for it
well those are two different issues now
by the way this is how democrats think
it's
i want to do this giant costly thing and
how do you pay for it according to
democrats are two completely separate
issues
uh in no other area of life does anyone
think like this if you say it's your
spouse today you know sweetheart i
really want a lamborghini i mean that is
a nice set of wheels i want a
lamborghini today and your wife says
well how are we going to pay for that we
can't afford it that's two separate
issues guys the lamborghini is super
nice
and as for paying for it well we can
have that discussion a little bit later
this is how you bankrupt yourself is how
you bankrupt the state as well
ashkara says if we can agree on a policy
and get that policy passed then it
becomes more real then you're actually
telling the voters what they're voting
for that's really important in other
words you lead with the dependency and
then you tax everybody in order to pay
for the new free newly created
dependency
assembly republican leader mary waldron
said i'm in the health committee i look
forward to a robust discussion on the
impacts of socialized medicine in
california including how much taxes will
increase on the middle class the plan
for universal universal health care
requires at least a two-thirds vote in
both houses of the state legislature
after that the voters have to approve it
in a statewide election democrats have
large majorities hitting all of them to
support the tax increases will be
difficult the california taxpayers
association says it would raise taxes by
163 billion dollars per year on
businesses and individuals but that
number doesn't mean a lot to people
because when you talk about billions and
trillions none of these numbers mean
anything so what exactly
so what exactly do you think the the
tax rates mean well national review has
a good rundown on what exactly the the
tax rates are supposed to mean
what they mean is basically the end of
the world okay we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
simple fact that if something were to
happen to you you need to make sure that
your family is taken care of let's say
that you and your wife you bear a child
and this child is a very special child
this is the kind of child who could
theoretically change the world and
suddenly a noseless man appears from
nowhere and starts trying to kill your
child so you step in front of that
noseless man's fire and you take the hit
your son is scarred across his forehead
you perish in the flames
well you know that your son he might
have been better off just a little bit
if you'd actually bothered to get life
insurance instead of having to live
under the stairs at like a terrible
uncle's house instead you theoretically
could have just gotten some life
insurance and put him in a much better
financial position this is why you
should have headed over to
policygenius.com
shapiro to answer a few questions about
yourself in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price you could save 50 or
more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius
their licensed experts will help you
understand your options and apply for a
policy the policy genius team works for
you not the insurance companies you can
trust them to offer unbiased help and
advocate for you at every step until you
are covered policy genius does not add
on extra fees they don't sell your
information to third parties they have
thousands of five-star reviews across
google and trustpilot since 2014 policy
genius has helped over 30 million people
shop for insurance and place 120 billion
dollars in coverage head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro get your free
life insurance quotes see how much you
could say that's policygenius.com
shapiro okay so
california according to the tax
foundation is considering doubling its
taxes doubling it
according to jared walczyk writing for
the tax foundation a proposed
constitutional amendment in california
would increase taxes by 12 250
per household roughly doubling the
state's already high collections to fund
that single-payer health care system the
top marginal rate on wage income would
soar to 18 percent
just to be clear that means that if
you're making above say 500 000 in the
state of california you'll be paying an
income rate on every dollar that you
earn above that mark
so that means that on dollars you're
above that mark you're gonna pay that
plus the what is it 36
top federal tax rate
so 54 cents out of every dollar you make
above a certain point goes to the
government and that doesn't include any
of the other taxes so it looks more like
65 cents out of every dollar going to a
government of some kind
by the way nationally the median top
marginal rate is 5.3 percent you wonder
why people like me fled california for
florida where there is a zero percent
state tax rate by the way i told my wife
when we left at the when we left the top
marginal tax rate in the state of
california is about 13 i said within
three years it'll be 20.
she was like nah
yes
yes within three years it will be 20
because the left cannot abide the idea
that rich people are not paying for
every single thing that they could ever
possibly want they're like spoiled
children
by the way that is not the only tax
increase that california is currently
contemplating
the state also wants to adopt a 2.3
gross receipts tax that is a rate of
more than three times that of the
country's highest current pure grt so
what exactly is a gross receipt tax a
gross receipt tax means any dollar that
your business receives will now be taxed
at 2.3 percent in the state of
california
what makes this weird well let's say
that your business makes 10 million
dollars this year but your costs are 12
million this year so you're actually
running in the red you're not a
profitable business
according to the state of california you
are still going to have to drop 2.3
percent of your gross receipts
2.3 percent of your gross receipts
into
the state tax coffers a couple hundred
thousand dollars even though you're
already running 20
below margin
so your entire profit margin is gone if
you're profitable and if you're not
profitable then you're paying on top 2.3
just to operate
the new taxes would take three forms sur
taxes atop the current individual income
tax structure beginning at 149 000
in income
a graduated rate payroll tax system with
the top rate kicking in for employees
with more
hundred than 49
dollars in annual income and a gross
receipts tax of two point three percent
by the way how bizarre is this bill this
bill is so bizarre that if you have 50
employees then you have to pay more in
terms of payroll tax if you have 49
employees you don't have to pay more in
payroll tax what this means is that if
you are paying your 50th employee a
little bit under 50 000 a year
you would never hire that person because
they're going to cost you about 90 000 a
year
there are two states that currently have
payroll taxes for purposes other than
funding their unemployment insurance
system in massachusetts there's a
recently adopted payroll tax of 0.68
it's dropped atop that state's 5.0 flat
individual income tax in nevada there's
a 1.5 percent
on payroll tax
and uh they add that to their their
income tax well actually nevada doesn't
have an income tax california would
impose a payroll tax of up to 2.25
percent atop an individual income tax
that already has the top marginal rate
of 13.3 and they want to jog that to 18
this is insane so as i say the payroll
tax exempts employers with fewer than 50
resident employees punishing small
businesses for expanding and creating a
meaningful tax cliff imagine for
instance the overly simplified
hypothetical of a company with 49
employees making 80 grand each at 49
employees the company has no payroll tax
burden if you hire one additional
employee that generates a tax bill of 90
grand more than the employee's entire
salary
a gross receipts tax are going to drive
business out of state none of this is
shocking it's just insane it's totally
totally insane
again that top tax bracket in the state
of california would kick in that 18 tax
bracket would kick in about 2.4 million
dollars but if you are making above say
299 000 actually 150 000 in the state of
california under the new plan you would
still be paying 12
income tax in the state of california
that is not a ton of money 150 000
and that's for a couple by the way that
is not for a single
so all of this is crazy but california
is going to pursue it and then they're
shocked when people leave cnbc points
out yesterday uh yeah you can see just
from the census how americans are
leaving high tax states for low tax age
because it turns out people are economic
actors
we've heard the anecdotes now we have
the actual numbers more than 600 000
people leaving new york and california
for lower tax states during the pandemic
that's according to census data
california lost 300 000 residents
between april of 2020 and july of 2021
new york lost a net
365 000 people
about two percent of its total
population now the biggest winners not
surprisingly were texas and florida
which have of course no income taxes
texas gaining 382 000 florida adding 243
000 now people move for many reasons
lower housing prices lower cost of
living with remote work their families
may be there
but there is a continued shift from high
tax to low tax states
so keep it up keep sending your revenue
down to us here in florida we are more
than happy to take it just leave your
bullcrap politics where they were when
you come that means you facebook
apparently facebook's parent company
meta has now signed the largest ever
lease in downtown austin
according to fox business the tallest
tower in austin texas still under
construction will soon be home to meta
platforms that's the parent company of
facebook
which is not a surprise
silicon valley is relocating to austin
and nashville and florida and everywhere
else miami is now becoming a financial
hub because everybody's getting the hell
out of california and new york and by
the way along with these universal
healthcare proposals there are some
social proposals that are going to come
into play because it turns out that when
california provides quote unquote
universal healthcare to everyone it's
going to come along with the social
values california is famous for
you can you can already see this
happening in washington state our friend
jason rants over at 770 ktth
mynorthwest.com he points out that
washington state now appears to allow
minors to undergo life-changing gender
reassignment surgery without parental
consent under a new law health insurers
must cover gender affirming care
including surgical treatments that were
previously denied coverage democrats
rejected a proposal to apply the new law
to patients over 18 years old that means
that children as young as 13 years old
can make the health care decision to
undergo gender reassignment surgery
without parental consent
and insurers are forced to cover it
if you don't think that's going to
happen in california when they have
quote unquote universal healthcare run
by the state and they essentially get
rid of private insurers all together
which is what you sort of have to do
you are out of your mind that's exactly
what they're going to do and then they
wonder why the rush continues to red
state so you know what more of this more
of this
i'm in favor of federalism
and um and i'm very much in favor of
california burning itself out so that we
can take all of their productive
citizens i was one of the productive
citizens of california all my life and
now i took my company with 150 employees
and we put it in nashville took another
10 employees came down to south florida
and let me tell you everybody's happier
everybody's wealthier because that is
the way that incentive structures work
but what is the left left with what
they're left with is an unearned sense
of moral superiority that's what it
comes down to unearned moral superiority
is all that the left has left and right
now they are getting high on their own
farts with regard to covid okay so here
is the thing about covid we're all
getting it okay omicron will hit
everyone triple dexed double vax
quadruple facts you're all getting it
the reason is because it is not going to
prevent transmission again the cdc
announced this yesterday if you said
that before the cdc did they would ban
you from youtube but now richarlinsky
has said it so i'm allowed to say it
because that's the way our
ridiculously censorious and tyrannical
social media apps work if the government
says it now i'm allowed to say it if the
government doesn't say it i'm not
allowed to say it
but the left must cling to its sense of
moral superiority over the vaccine now
here's the thing i've been saying all
along and i think that if you are
vulnerable you should get the vax i
think that in virtually all cases people
above the age of 18 have higher risk
factors from coped than they do from the
vaccine
so that means they should probably get
the vaccine again i am double vaxxed my
wife is triple that's my parents are
triple vaxxed so i'm a fan of the
vaccine
okay that does not mean that if you
choose not to get vaccinated i am
rooting openly for your death and yet
that is exactly what some people on the
left are doing because it makes them
feel superior it makes them feel as
though this entire pandemic can be
blamed on you as opposed to on their own
stupid decisions i've been making the
points since the vaccines were available
which was february march of this year
that now we all get to make our own
decisions and you should leave everybody
else alone the left can't let go of that
because if they were to let go of it
then they might be admitting that
perhaps freedom is a better solution
than government tyranny and that the
government is incapable of fulfilling
promises the left believes it can make
the left believes the universal health
care means that everybody is healthy
that is not what that means hey check
out the nhs and britain that is not what
it means the left believes that when the
government promises it can keep you safe
from an epidemic virus that means it can
keep you safe from an epidemic virus
that is not true
and so now they have to find someone
else to blame that's not the government
what are they going to blame the unbaxed
now again
if you die because you are unvaxed i
think that you have made a generally
poor decision because the vaccine does
prevent hospitalization and death in
large measure
it's not as effective as it was ten
months ago that's why some people are
getting boosted but it does create
t-cell and b-cell immunity and that is a
very good thing
however does anyone should anyone be
quote unquote laughing at those who are
unvexed who die i mean you don't even
know why they're on facts maybe they're
on facts because they had natural
immunity maybe they died from a
complicated condition but according to
michael hilsick a business columnist for
the la times
mocking anti-vaxxers covet deaths is
ghoulish yes but may be necessary that
by the way is not the html address at
the top of the column the html address
at the top of the column is why
shouldn't we dance on the graves of
anti-vaxxers
the answer is because it makes you a
crappy human being i don't dance atop
the graves of people who are obese who
die of heart attacks
like why would you dance to top
anybody's grave because they die of a
health condition that's absurd
but for the left
the the it of the left apparently thinks
this is okay so michael holzick says
among all the ways that coven 19 affects
our lives the pandemic confronts us with
a profound moral dilemma
how should we react to the deaths of the
unvaccinated so i have a question why is
that a profound moral dilemma
it seems like a pretty easy moral
dilemma we should be sad when people die
of health conditions generally speaking
we should be sad
i mean i i honestly i see no distinction
morally between people who are saying
like michael hiltzek that you should be
celebrating the death of the
unvaccinated and people in the 1980s who
were saying that if somebody died of
aids it's probably because they deserved
it both are crappy moral stances i don't
understand
on the one hand says michael hilsick a
hallmark of civilized thought is the
sense that every life is precious on the
other those who have deliberately
flouted sober medical advice by refusing
a vaccine known to reduce the risk of
serious disease from the virus including
the risk to others and end up in the
hospital or the grave can be viewed as
receiving their just desserts
that's even more true of those who not
only refuse the vaccine for themselves
but publicly advocate that others do so
it has become common online and in
social media for vaccine refusers and
anti-vaxx advocates to become the target
of ridicule after they come down with
coca-19 and especially if they die from
it
witness the subreddit herman cain award
which lily woothborough of slate
identified in september as quite a sight
for heartless and unrepentant
schadenfreud
the site is named for the former
republican candidate for president who
became one of the first political
notables to succumb to the disease after
publicly defying social distancing
measures but
wait a second i thought that herman cain
was there any information that herman
cain was unboxed
i'm unclear on that we'll have to check
that out i'm pretty sure that the
question for herman cain was about
social distancing and social distancing
as it turns out
is kind of made up and arbitrary when it
comes to that six foot rule
particularly like the cdc admits that
the issue of how to think about the
deaths of the unvaccinated has been
thrown into high relief locally by the
case of kelly earnby a prominent orange
county republican and deputy district
attorney who advocated against vaccine
mandates and died of coveted around new
year's day unvaccinated so i have a
question isn't there a difference
between advocating against vaccine
mandates and advocating against vaccines
the idea here from the left is that we
have to expand the definition of
anti-vaxxer to mean that if i don't
think you should be forced to get the
vaccine this means i'm anti-vaxxed which
is crazy
so says michael hiltzek i have a
different take to begin with let's
stipulate that not all people unvexed
for covet are alike some have remained
unvaccinated for legitimate medical
reasons some may have legitimately faced
obstacles in getting to a vaccination
site others may have refused the vaccine
because they've been deceived finally
there are those who have voiced public
opposition to the vaccines not all of
them are unvaccinated themselves some
have couched their opposition in policy
terms
ernie fell into that category she
asserted opposition not to the vaccines
as such but to vaccination mandates
she said i don't think the government
should be involved in mandating what
vaccines that people are taking
that town hall predated the pandemic but
ernie made clear her opposition extended
to covet vaccines in august she posted a
statement on her facebook page
supporting huntington beach firefighters
who are opposing a vax mandate
the vaccine is not accurate to covet and
mandates won't work she wrote okay so
mandates have not worked and the vaccine
is not in fact a cure to covet that
she's she's not wrong about that the
vaccine is preventative against
hospitalization and death in large
measure that doesn't mean it's a
quote-unquote cure
it should be clear that opposing vax
mandates as a substitute for opposing
vaccination itself is a fundamentally
incoherent position says michael hiltig
it's a little more than a garden variety
small government republican ideology
that's what it was in earn these hands
contrary to earn these assertions
mandates do work blah blah blah blah
blah blah so the bottom line is he's not
actually saying that if you die unboxed
that's bad he's saying if you oppose any
elements of my agenda you deserve to die
which is totally crazy he says mockery
is not necessarily the wrong reaction to
those who publicly mocked anti-coveted
measures and encouraged others to follow
suit before they perished of the disease
the dangers of which they belittled you
have to belittle the dangers of kobet in
order to recognize that government
crackdowns may be over broad blunderbuss
instruments that are violative of
american freedoms
it's not wrong says michael hildsich to
deny them our sympathy and solicitude or
to make sure it's known when their
deaths are marked that they had stood
fast against measures they might have
protected themselves and others from the
fate they succumbed to here's the
problem omicron is coming for all y'all
but the left can't let it go unearned
moral superiority is the name of the
game we'll get to more of that in just
one second first let's talk about
getting your mortgage refinance so
you're paying too much for your mortgage
right now if you haven't refinanced in
the last couple of years because the
rates are really really low timing the
market can be a dangerous game so if
you're holding off on a mortgage refi in
the hopes that the rates drop you might
want to rethink your strategy i mean the
latest forecasts project a few interest
rate hikes this year alone the first
increase could come in the next month
making now the best time to call
american financing
take advantage of a free no obligation
mortgage review where you will learn
about custom loan options that can save
you up to a thousand bucks a month
that's right every month from lower
rates to shorter terms even debt
consolidation they can do it all and
they never charge upfront or hidden fees
so why not see what they can do for you
if you like what you hear you can
pre-qualify for free possibly skip two
mortgage payments you might close in as
fast as 10 days just call 866 721
that's
866-721-3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls 182 334 and mls consumeraccess.org
give them a call at 866 721 3300 or
visit
americanfinancing.net to get started now
is a great time for a mortgage refi
don't wait until it's too late
americanfinancing.net okay so again the
left their policies have failed and so
they are left with nothing but unearned
moral superiority based in fiction so
for example sunny hostin of the view who
you know there's sort of a running gun
battle on the view as to who is the
stupidest person on the view there are a
lot of not particularly bright people on
the view sunny hostin in my view uh is
the worst of the the people on the view
she is just awful she repeatedly repeats
things that are untrue she just says
things straight out that are flat out
lies here she was yesterday trying to
defend justice sonia sotomayor's bizarre
assertion that a hundred thousand
children were in the hospital thanks to
covet which is totally crazy the actual
number is like 3 500 and most of them
are totally fine many of them are in the
hospital with like a broken leg and
covet
they're not in the hospital for covert
here is sonny hostin trying to make the
case that tonya sotomayor is correct
that the left should get get to cram
down whatever policy they want on you
based on pure
fiction she may not be accurate for
current hospitalizations
um in children she is correct that we
have more children in the hospital
now more than ever before
and it certainly reflects the current
cases in children right now we have
eighty two thousand eight hundred and
forty three um children uh sick with
with covid more than a thousand children
have died from the virus um and in
addition about seven point eight million
children have caught covet since uh the
pandemic started and and so so that that
those are just just the numbers and so
um while fewer than 83 000 kids have
been hospitalized with the virus we have
kids sick with kova more than we ever
have before and so that's a real thing
and those are real numbers
okay but uh sotomayor did not cite real
numbers and by the way the current
the current death count for kids under
the age of 18 remains below 700 for two
years of pandemic
and new studies suggest that for kids
hospitalized between the ages of 12 and
17 66 of them were obese
there are significant underlying
conditions that contribute to whether or
not you are going to die of covid
according to the cdc itself quote
covert 19 was the only cause mentioned
on the death certificate for about five
percent of deaths for deaths with
conditions or causes in addition to
cover 19 on average there were 4.0
additional conditions or causes per
death
and that is according to the cdc
so yeah again the the sort of panic
stricken notions of the left are
designed to suggest that you are bad if
you oppose them which is why again there
is no case anymore for the biden
administration pushing forward with its
vast mandate omicron has totally killed
it the entire basis for the employer vax
mandate was that you have to stop the
spread of your workplace but you're not
stopping the spread everyone is getting
omicron
now you on an individual level as i've
said i'm going to say it again you on an
individual level if you're above the age
of 18 your chances that you're going to
get seriously ill or die from covid are
still better than the chances you're
going to get seriously ill or die from
the vaccine absent some sort of
complicating factor which is why you
should talk to your doctor and your
doctor will probably recommend that you
get the vaccine
but
that does not mean that the federal
government has the power through osha of
all things to mandate that you get a
vaccine that is predominantly geared
toward protecting you not toward
protecting others
nonetheless the bulk of the vaccine
mandate has now taken effect according
to the wall street journal as of january
10th all employers with more than 100
employees must have a procedure in place
to ensure employees are vaccinated and
keep track of workers vaccination status
employers must also track whether their
workers are infected and keep those who
test positive away from work workers who
are not vaccinated must wear a mask
while indoors the labor department in
december gave employers an extra month
to require that unvaccinated employees
take weekly covet 19 tests that goes
into effect february 9th the rule covers
about 84 million workers we are still
awaiting the outcome of the supreme
court case that was heard on friday
meanwhile the bite administration
continues to maintain that people will
die if the vax mandate is struck down
well i'm going to need some evidence
that people are going to die if the
vaccine mandate is struck down given the
fact that everyone is associating
outside of work also these people act
like the only place you ever see anybody
else is inside work
and that and that the vast mandate
inside work is going to stop
transmission which of course is very
silly here's hhs secretary
xavier becerra
hopefully the plan is that the supreme
court will recognize that the federal
government the bite administration has
the authority to require these vaccines
we know they work they save lives uh
we've proven it here at hhs with 88 000
workers nearly a hundred percent of our
workers are vaccinated already and it is
important
and if they don't well i think that will
be on their conscience i i think there's
some clear authority legal authority for
us to move forward as we have proposed
both for the private sector workforce
and for the health care workforce and we
understand that if we don't get people
vaccinated and covered this way people
will die and if you're a health care
worker for sure
i have a more basic i have a more basic
question here okay the more basic
question here is if everybody is going
to get omicron anyway
why are we actually attempting to
prevent the spread this is a serious
question and we should think it through
logically
if the argument is that you should get
vaccinated i generally agree for the
third time in this particular episode i
totally agree with that however if
omicron is making its way around why
should we be attempting to shield you
from getting omicron at all given the
fact that there could be future variants
that are significantly more deadly right
delta was more deadly than omicron as in
like three to four times more deadly
than omicron are you supposed to just
wait out there and take the chance that
you will be able to avoid this disease
forever or maybe you're better off
getting a mild version of the disease
my friend vivek rama swamy and his wife
apoorva ramaswamy who's a doctor
they have a piece today in the wall
street journal titled slow the spread
speeding it may be safer the omicron
variant is spreading across the globe
but so far the strain appears to be less
deadly than its predecessors that's good
news here's a risk that policymaker in
every country should appreciate policies
designed to slow the spread of omicron
may end up creating a supervariance that
is more infectious more virulent more
resistant to vaccines which would be a
man-made disaster
to minimize that risk policymakers must
tolerate the rapid spread of mild
ovarians this will require difficult
trade-offs but it will save lives in the
long run we should add mass mandates and
social resistancing in most settings not
because they don't slow the spread the
usual argument against such measures but
because they probably do so either way
you probably shouldn't be engaging in
these sorts of measures says
say the rama swami's this is correct if
they don't slow the spread then there's
no reason for them and if they do slow
the spread then what exactly are you
waiting for are you waiting for a new
variant that's going to become even
milder because that's taking an awful
chance considering that omicron is
significantly milder than delta in the
first place by the way the number of
cases like 1.5 million cases in the
united states per day at this point let
me just point out that's way too low
that is way too low i know a lot of
people who have not tested positive for
coven who almost certainly have coveted
and that does not mean that they are out
there killing everybody it just means
that everybody's getting omicron
say the rama swami is to understand why
first consider an important scientific
distinction between antigenic drift and
antigenic shift antigens are molecules
such as the spike protein of sars covet
ii that the immune system detects as
foreign the host immune system then
mounts a response antigenic drift
describes the process by which a single
point mutation randomly occurs during
the viral replication process the result
is minor alterations to antigens like
the spike protein if a point mutation
makes the virus less likely to survive
that variant gradually dies off but if
the mutation confers an incremental
survival advantage say the ability to
spread more quickly from one cell to
another that strain becomes more likely
to spread through the population
antigenic drift is a gradual varying
process a single point mutation alters
one peptide or building block of a
larger protein hosts with immunity
against a prior strain generally enjoy
at least partial immunity against
drifted variants this is called cross
protection
each time an immune host is exposed to a
slightly different antigenic variant the
host can tweak its immune response
without becoming severely ill and the
more similar the new strain is to the
last version the less risky that stream
will be to the host by contrast
antigenic shift refers to a
discontinuous quantum leap from one
antigen or set of antigens to a very
different antigen new viral strains such
as those that jump one species to
another tend to emerge from antigenic
shift the biological causes of antigenic
shift are often different from those of
drift for example the physical swap of
whole sections of the genome leads to
more significant changes to viral genes
than those caused by individual point
mutations but there is a sorodes paradox
how many unique point mutations
collectively constitute an antigenic
shift especially when human hosts are
deprived of opportunities to update
their immune response to drifted
variants
here's the key
a vaccinated and naturally immune people
can revamp their immune response to new
viral strains but created by antigenic
drift but social distancing and masking
increased the risk of vaccine resistant
strains from antigenic shift by
minimizing opportunities for the
vaccinated and naturally immune to
tailor their immune responses through
periodic exposures to incrementally
drifted variants so to simplify what
they are saying is that there are new
variants they have slight changes if you
are exposed to these new variants your
body fights them off if you are never
exposed to new variants then this means
that after several changes you're going
to get a variant that is so different
from the original variant your body
doesn't know how to fight it off so
maybe we should stop focusing on
preventing transmission and we should
start focusing as always on
hospitalization and death and if those
numbers remain low
and if we are protecting and shielding
the most vulnerable there's not much
else that we should be doing
say the rama swamis the absolute risk of
a more virulent strain of stars covered
covetous is low that's because viruses
care more about propagating themselves
than about killing the host most viruses
evolved become more infectious and less
virulent but that's only a rule of thumb
not a biological law
mass mandates and social distancing
measures will have created fertile
ground for new variants that evade
vaccination even more effectively
significant antigenic shifts may create
new strains that are increasingly
difficult to target with vaccines at all
there are no vaccines for many viruses
despite decades of effort to develop
them
by the way you can see how this is true
from the death stats in south africa and
the death stats in sweden south africa
had very little vaccination but everyone
got delta and then when omicron hit no
one died sweden
had a shield and protect strategy for
the elderly and the vulnerable and then
everybody else was allowed to go live
their life so a lot of people got delta
not a lot of people died and now they
had the best 2021 of pretty much any
country on the planet because everybody
in sweden was
was already immune to the virus
by the way i'm seeing headlines say
about sweden re-locking down by lockdown
sweden means they're shutting the
restaurants at 11 p.m when you normally
shut your restaurants guys
that thing down is a lockdown come on
by the way all of the all the outside
panic over the hospitals are being
overwhelmed we're all going to die the
stats demonstrate that this actually is
not true phil kerpin
who's on top of this stuff on twitter he
put out a chart demonstrating what the
hospitalizations look like okay
basically hospitalizations total staffed
inpatient beds fairly even and have been
since september of 2020
and as you will see there's an increase
in the number of confirmed covered
patients but there's really not a
massive increase in the number of
inpatient beds used
it's been pretty stable all the way
through the pandemic
so this belief that we are in in the
midst of a massive hospital shortage if
it is that's only because the biden vax
mandates have basically driven
healthcare workers out of the business
according to the wall street journal
rising numbers of nurses and other
critical healthcare workers are calling
in sick across the united states due to
cover 19 forcing hospitals to cut
capacity just as the omicron variant
sends them more patients
hospitals are leaving beds empty because
the facilities don't have enough
staffers to safely care for the patients
staff shortages prompted mass general
brigham hospital in boston to keep 83
beds empty on friday so i said on fox
news now it's ripped up and down by
media matters that the biden vax
mandates and the attempt to test all of
your healthcare employees is leading to
less healthcare which is leading to less
capacity that happens to be absolutely
true
limiting capacity is a last resort for
hospitals doctor and healthcare
officials say the facilities do it to
preserve proper care and safety for
current patients that means leaving
people in limbo in emergency rooms
making ambulances weight and postponing
treatment for cancer heart disease and
other conditions all to prevent the
transmission of a very very mild variant
of covid
it's pretty astonishing stuff
again and the federal government's
response here is completely confused and
confusing
and now by the way the pfizer ceo is
admitting that the two coveted vaccine
doses are quote unquote not enough for
omicron what he means by that is that
they are not preventing infection which
we already know
real world data from the uk has found
the two vaccine doses are 52 effective
at preventing hospitalization 25 weeks
after receiving the second shot
two doses of fiber or modernised
vaccines are only about 10 percent
effective at preventing infection from
omicron 20 weeks after the second dose
so basically you're going to get it okay
but that does not mean that you're going
to die here is here is the head of
pfizer announcing that everyone's going
to get infected basically
the two dose of a vaccine offer very
limited protection if any the three
doses with a booster
they offer reasonable protection against
hospitalization and deaths
in again there's nothing very good
and
less protection against the infection
okay so again the federal government
responds here is a complete mess
yesterday peter ducey asked gensoc you
guys keep saying this is a pandemic of
the unvaccinated i've noticed that um
everyone is getting this including you
who are triple x
i understand that the science says that
vaccines prevent death
but
i'm triple backed still got cobit your
triple backs still got cobit
why is the president still referring to
this as a pandemic
of the unvaccinated
and she says well you know because the
unvaccinated are the ones who are going
to the hospital which is true but that
does not change the fact that the
infections are being carried forward by
everyone by everyone alrighty in just
one second we'll get to the biden
administration's response to all of this
which is throw up your hands and start
talking about election law or something
we'll get to that in just one moment
first i'm thrilled to announce an
incredible app that everyone who buys
gas needs to know about get upside my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download that free get upside
app in the app store or google play
right now use promo code shapiro get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up that's up to 50 cents cash back
do not pay full price at the pump
anymore
get cash back using get upside just
download that app for free use promo
code shapiro to get up to 50 cents per
gallon cash back on your very first tank
of gas some people who drive a lot are
making as much as two to 300 bucks a
month in cash back there is no catch the
cash back gets added directly to your
account you can cash out any time it's
your bank account paypal or any gift
card for amazon and other brands
just download that free get upside app
use promo code shapiro get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your very
first tank of gas gas prices are just
too high right now i think we all know
that brandon is at least partially to
blame and that is why you should get
that get upside app right now again use
promo code shapiro get up to 50 cents
per gallon cash back on your first tank
of gas and then up to 25 cents per
gallon off for every subsequent tank of
gas use promo code shapiro when you
download that free get upside app from
the app store alrighty we'll get some
more in just one second as everybody
knows right now the daily wire is
rapidly expanding into entertainment
with that expansion we are searching for
a council of business and legal affairs
to join our legal team in nashville as
our in-house legal expert on the film
and television industry the council of
business and legal affairs will manage
all legal aspects of the daily wires
entertainment content including
development acquisition production and
finance as well as production legal and
intellectual property work for all of
the daily wires shows we need someone
with eight plus years of experience in
the film and tv industry this is a
perfect opportunity for an entertainment
lawyer who's ready to get out of
hollywood's woke group think to apply
for that opportunity and to view a full
list of our current openings at daily
wire because we are a fast growing
company please visit dailywire.com
careers also if you haven't heard of
jonathan isaac yet you might be living
under a rock because jonathan isaac is
awesome he's the nba star who stood
strong with his values while everyone
else in the nba was kneeling for the lie
that america was systemically racist and
evil jonathan isaac stood he would not
kneel with the rest of his teammates he
faced heavy criticism from the media for
his views on social issues and vaccines
over the past few years which is why i'm
so excited to announce he has decided to
write a book with the daily wire it's
called why i stand you should buy the
book and show him your support
jonathan's book will be about the rise
of his basketball career his journey
into faith his strength to stand alone
in the face of immense pressure check
out this teaser the orlando magic's 23
year old starting forward is deeply
religious and proudly unvaccinated on
friday isaac got attention for choosing
not to kneel in unison with his
teammates or to wear a black lives
matter shirt my name is jonathan isaac i
play for the orlando magic
and i'm writing a book with the daily
wire
[Music]
coverage does not mean the absence of
fear and in today's day there are so
many things that you can be afraid of
facing because of believing what you
believe or deciding to stand for what
you believe in and i believe this book
gives you a blueprint of my story of how
christ has made the difference in my
life from a young kid who struggled with
fear anxiety
self-insecurity to a man willing to
stand for what he believes
[Music]
jonathan's book will be one of the very
first under the daily wires new
publishing arm dw books we couldn't be
happier to have him on board the book is
available for pre-order right now at
amazon so reserve your copy today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
well joe biden's administration is on
the rocks they've got millions of new
cases of omicron they have no way of
handling it because they boxed
themselves in and their message on
inflation continues to be so bad that
even the washington post editorial board
is like guys
what are you talking about here is the
washington post editorial board today
quote president biden is facing mounting
criticism for inflation's rise to its
highest level since 1982.
unfortunately the white house's latest
response is to blame greedy businesses
economists across the political spectrum
are rightly calling out the white house
for this foolishness even some within
the white house are questioning this
approach the post reports
inflation which was relatively low for
decades did not suddenly rise in recent
months because businesses decided now
was their ideal time to squeeze their
customers what actually happened is the
demand soared for many products as the
economy recovered often there were not
enough products to meet it in a surprise
to many consumers kept buying goods like
cars and washing machines even at higher
prices
what the white house is really
struggling with is an inflation
messaging problem officials initial
insistence that higher prices would be
short-lived flopped as the annual
inflation has now been about five
percent since june
the reality is that the best tool the
nation has to fight inflation is the
federal reserve raising interest rates
but the fed operates independently from
the white house biden could help by
finally announcing his nominees for the
three seats on the federal reserve's
board of governors they're saying that
we should destroy the federal reserve's
independence in order to save joe biden
but what they really mean is that joe
biden is incredibly bad at this job so
what this means is that joe biden now
has to rely on a secondary message for
2022 and so do the democrats that
secondary message is republicans are
trying to stymie the vote hey this is
all crazy talk if they think this is
going to work they're crazy first of all
more democrats voted in the last
election cycle than in any election
cycle in american history and it is not
close the turnout rates were
extraordinary joe biden won 81 million
votes okay those are big numbers
if there's election stifling going on
and there is no evidence that there is
election stifling going on there's less
evidence that people are being kept from
voting in the united states and that
people are engaging in widespread voter
fraud less evidence and so for all the
people on the left you keep saying that
donald trump is propagating the big lie
by talking about electoral fraud and
that in the notion that he won the 2020
election
it is a much bigger lie when you suggest
that there are millions of people being
disenfranchised at the ballot box that
is just a lie it is not true at all and
yet this is what democrats are relying
upon
so nancy pelosi goes the furthest she
basically makes the argument that
conservatives republicans they ought to
be treated like terrorists she says
january 6 with a terror attack and then
she also says
that republicans in the states who are
pursuing voter verification methods they
are just a continuation of the terror
attacks of january 6. basically you're
all terrorists i i do have to note here
that whoever is doing nancy pelosi's
botox needs to be stopped
someone needs to be stopped here she has
gone full jack nicholson joker fell
directly into the vat of toxic waste i
don't know what's going on here you know
those of us who who suffer from a family
receding hairline i've never seen before
receding eyebrows that is a new one her
eyebrows are literally receding all the
way up her face they started off just
above her eyes and now they are halfway
up her forehead and if she continues in
this manner her eyebrows will eventually
be all the way at the back of her head
she'll be talking you'll just see her
eyebrows wiggling all the way up here i
don't know what's going on like these
are the people who run our country
here is nancy pelosi crazy nancy pelosi
who looks like
a a marionette like an edgar berg and
marionette talking about how you are
basically a terrorist if you support
voter id
there's nothing more important for us to
do
than protect our constitution and our
democracy what the republicans are doing
across the country is really a a
legislative continue continuation of
what they did on january 6th which is to
undermine
our democracy
it's a legislative continuation of
january 6 undermining our democracy is
the line
so this is the line they're gonna carry
into 2022. good luck with this you've
got bad inflation you've got bad coveted
policy you've got underemployment
because not enough people are getting
back into the labor force you have a
completely failed foreign policy and
nancy pelosi's pitch is that everybody
who is pushing voter id in states like
georgia was complicit in january 6th
really good luck with this and then
trotting out maxine waters to back this
my goodness you guys have a very very
weak pitch here is maxine waters doing
the same thing last night
this is not something uh that they have
any real issues about relative to how
the system is working whether it's this
that or the other this is about racism
this is about exclusion this is about
not wanting us to be able uh to
participate in the policies that govern
this country
it's about racism and exclusion and uh
and also you should confront people you
don't like in parking lots and scream at
uh also i i will admit that that i was
not expecting the john lennon
1980s style so like john lennon was dead
by that point but um if he had blown up
those sunglasses the crazy sunglasses
made them very large and plunked them
down on on maxine waters that would have
been the look this is great by the way
chuck schumer is trying to force a vote
on the filibuster like this is how
desperate they are he's now
demonstrating his own incompetence he's
demonstrating full skill his own
incompetence
the senate majority leader is going to
try to vote on the filibuster and see if
kristin cinema in arizona and joe
manchin are going to kill the filibuster
on behalf of voting rights bill that
does not have majority support
good luck with that and then what's he
going to claim what is biden going to
claim what's truman going to claim that
he's been obstructed by republicans when
he can't even get his own democrats on
board
seriously they are so incompetent and
they are so boxed in and 2022 is gonna
be so ugly for them until they are left
merely with dreams of universal health
care and a hatred for those who don't
think like them if that's your pitch
you're gonna get skunked come november
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon is the matt wall show it
airs 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wydowsky associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high events audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show